[Music]
[Music]
good evening they have opened up the
upper balcony for those of you just
coming in feel free to fill in up there
it's gonna be a very visual show and
it'll be great seats up there
so please enjoy tonight's as many of you
know we start these talks often with a
short film that somehow exemplifies long
term thinking along the theme of the
evenings talk and actually for tonight
the long short was selected by our
speaker Nikki case please enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
pace is everything the physicist David
Deutsch claims that science basically
advances from explanation to explanation
explanation and civilization and sense
follows the same track the other side of
an explanation is understanding and one
of the synonyms for saying I understand
is I see someone just exceptionally good
at seeing is our speaker nikki case so
you may remember playing this game as a
kid monopoly or what it should be called
the game that the ends friendships and
destroys families so yeah most of us
remember suffering through this
excruciating experience but what you may
not know is that monopoly was based off
another earlier and in my opinion better
game monopoly has a secret history so in
the year Oh 1866 Elizabeth McKee was
born the daughter of an abolitionist who
traveled around with Abraham Lincoln and
when she was young her father introduced
her to the economic philosophy of Henry
George who saw the monopolies of their
time as a problem and advocated a unique
solution that would keep the free market
systems innovation but not as
inequalities and Lizzie was enthralled
when she was 37
she created a board game that took the
complex systems of George's economic
philosophy and explained them in a
visual tangible and playful way she
called her game the landlord's game
it came out 30 years before monopoly and
it played like a slimmer less
soul-crushing version of Monopoly but
here's the strangest thing Lizzie
intentionally designed her game to be
broken it worked like this if you play
non Monopoly you already know what
happens
players go around the board buying
property collecting rents from the
property but this creates a vicious
cycle where someone gets a very small
edge at the start and it's already
guaranteed they're gonna be the winner
in 15 minutes so everyone has to wait
for like four hours for the sweet
release of death and that was Lizzie's
point that this economic system of land
rent was terrible it is a broken game
but Lizzie didn't want to just show a
systemic problem she wants to show a
systemic solution so she later made an
add-on to her game and altogether she
called them the landlord's game and
prosperity so it worked like this after
everyone played the landlord's game and
it was incredibly ticked off by it they
would then switch over to prosperity and
so far parity has the same rules as the
landlord's game but with one change
instead of paying the full rent to the
landlord part of the lorentz will be
paid to the middle of the board some
communal fund and those funds in the
middle of the board would be used to buy
back the monopolies that happened during
the landlord's game so first they will
buy back the utilities and then buy back
the railroads and then finally if
there's excess funds in the middle
they'll use it to create a universal
basic income
which is actually what the go mechanism
in monopoly supposed to be you go around
the board you pick go past go and you
get your basic income that was actually
bad
and according to the Lizzy's
interpretation of George economics with
this one change in this one rule what
was once a vicious cycle has now become
a virtuous cycle and everyone enjoys
prosperity anyway then some guy stole
her design turning the crap and sold off
the pocket buzzers and it all the family
ever after but anyway this talk is not
about some obscure 19th century economic
philosophy that may or may not work so
why did I bring up the story of
Elizabeth Nikki well one we live in a
post TED talk world so I need to always
start a talk of a story in two because
Lizzie's creation is my personal
favorite example of seeing whole systems
talk hi I'm Nikki case and I explain
complex systems in a visual tangible and
playful way I've made games and
simulations about social trust
environmental economics mental health
political polarization alternative
voting systems and fireflies because
fireflies are awesome and since you're
here listening to this long I'll talk
you probably have a goal you want to
slay a dragon we all care about some big
problem
global warming terrorism pandemics
poverty crime war you know the usual
and these big problems are not the
dragon the dragon is the set of systems
that come that create these problems the
dragon is complexity the dragon is chaos
now you may be thinking what am I saying
that a bunch of board games and stick
figures will help save the world I'm
saying is yeah sure why not because
there's three reasons why it's important
to not just abstractly understand or
describe these whole systems but to
really see these whole systems and the
first reason is to make the abstract
concrete
because scientific progress is not made
by scientists floating up an abstract
land and going higher and higher into
abstract world now it's made when we
bring these abstract ideas down to our
level where we can see it with our
monkey eyes feel it with our monkey
fingers a lot of people think that
visualization is just eye candy it's
just a way to gift-wrap ideas and
deliver it to the masses real scientists
can work in just purely abstractions
right well considered the following in
the 1940s french mathematician jacques
hadamard surveyed a hundred of the top
physicists and mathematicians at this
time and he asked them how do you do
your thing how do you think and it turns
out that only a very very few of them
actually think in mathematical symbols
or use them in their day to day
imagination and work while all of them
reported seeing what their theory is
seeing their work and actually a full
third of them actually felt their ideas
and theories in their hands in their
muscles including Albert Einstein this
is one of the very rare insane quotes
that's actually in Einstein quotes
and it goes like this
the words of the language do not seem to
play any role in my mechanism of thought
thoughts are in my case of a visual and
muscular type Wow so no real scientists
don't just float up an abstract land
they bring it down to the human level
and so yes visualization can help us
organize our thoughts within ourselves
but they also help us communicate
thoughts so number two is to foster
communication because if we want to
tackle the big problems we have to
tackle it together
different people different fields need
to communicate with all with one needs
one another however when it comes to
communication words are terrible as
someone who's using words right now I
can show you they are pretty terrible so
actually when I was flying in a couple
days ago from Canada the border guard
asked me oh so what are you coming here
for and I said
I'm giving a talk and he said Oh what
about and I said visualizing systems so
what does that mean I have no idea cuz
yeah system the word system itself is
the most vague and frankly useless word
out there I mean that's probably vaguer
anymore useless words but anyway system
and on the other hand I could use more
technical and precise jargon like
nonlinear dynamics self-organization
theory but that would be one jargon
makes it harder not just to talk with
the public and policymakers who we will
need for solving these big problems but
jargon Olson makes it hard to talk to
someone who's outside of your field or
even outside of your own subfield
however I think talking in pictures gets
you the best of both worlds because
pictures are specific unlike a word like
system but they're also Universal unlike
nonlinear dynamical Dobler
so you need both pictures and words you
need to both show and tell so once
everyone's using visualization to see
their own thoughts and to
show their own thoughts to others what's
all that for
well number three visualizations can
help to guide us on our course official
ization is kind of like a map and uh you
know so maps have three purposes one
they show what we do know they show what
we don't yet know but most importantly
they guide us through a complex and
unknown territory and now you'll be
thinking well we can't possibly map a
whole system seeing whole systems you
can't do that and you're right actually
so I don't know why I get this talk you
know you're right you cannot see whole
systems and you shouldn't here's what
happens when you try to map a whole
system
this is an actual slide from a military
presentation given a few years ago it's
about the war in Afghanistan and one of
the generals said when one when a slide
came up one of the generals said once we
can understand this slide we'll have won
the war as you may have inferred we do
not understand this slide which is the
point this is a bad map because even
though it's incredibly detailed it
doesn't give guidance to give like a
complete opposite example let's contrast
this to this map of where we are right
now in San Francisco this map is
obviously wrong roads are not white and
yellow words aren't floating in the air
but the buildings are not gray
featureless blocks and if there was a
giant red guitar pick floating above us
right now I think we would have noticed
that by now but even though it has all
the details wrong it's incredibly useful
because yeah but you all know that every
map is simplified but few people
understand that maps are not useful
despite being simplified they're useful
precisely because they're simplified so
that's why in this talk I want to give
you the tools that's the three simple
tools so that you see and play with
systems
I want you after this
or tomorrow to be able to pick up a pen
get a scrap of paper I didn't bring the
paper and draw the systems in your own
field or the big problems you care about
so that's the reveal why this isn't just
a gimmick that's why I hand through all
200 of my slides which took forever
that dragon took me two hours thank you
but yeah these tools that you can do and
see in play with your own with drawing
these tools are concrete they help you
communicate and they'll help guide
Humanity on our course and as we set
sail on our course to unknown worlds we
best heed the advice of ancient maps
here be dragons so once upon the time
and yeah I'm doing the whole star of a
story thing again once upon a time the
British colonialists in India had a
problem stent specifically venomous
cobras now the Indian population was you
know used to these venomous creatures
but the British colonialists were pretty
terrified and wants it to fix this
problem so they put up a bounty for
every dead Cobra you bring in good sorry
you could get some cash and for a while
to seem to work people were bringing in
dead cobras too bad the population
wasn't actually going down because
that's when the British realized the
population was not going down even
though they became all these dead cobras
because it turned out some smart
enterprising people were actually
farming
[Music]
these cobras knowing that they could
make pretty good money doing so once the
British found out that oh crap we didn't
know these savages would actually be
intelligent human beings like the rest
of us they they canceled their bounty
and which meant there was no longer a
financial incentive to keep the Cobras
around so they'd you let them all go now
a disclosure this story is apocryphal so
but one this isn't exactly the only
example of the British Empire messing up
India and to the bigger point of this
story is whenever we try to slay the
dragon of complexity it turns out it's
not just a dragon
not just any dragon it's a Hydra you
chop one head off and two more growing's
place too many drunk people let's
prepare a bit alcohol oh no now
gangsters like Al Capone exist too much
disease let's put antibiotics in all our
livestock oh no now antibiotic resistant
superbugs exist I think the reason why
we get so many Hydra problems is because
we tend to think that cause and effect
is linear a causes B because of C and so
on and if you're more sophisticated you
might say that Oh
multiple causes for one thing and one
thing has multiple effects but that's
still like lines it still lines of
causality it's still linear but the
thing is the world is not linear it's
loopy a thing can be its own cause or
effects later in time it feeds back onto
itself
that's why it's called a feedback loop
but now how do we see and play with
these feedback loops
well pretty simple you get a piece of
paper and you're getting yourself a pen
this one's for smirk whatever I'm not
gonna do probably placements first you
draw a bunch of circles for whatever
things you want to represent like say a
simple ecosystem hairs in links
then you draw the relationship between
these things so for example here I've
drawn an arrow with a plus sign from
hares the Linksys because more hares
means more Linksys because hares feed
lynxes with their bodies and to complete
the loop Lynx's from nexus the hares I
have a minus sign with the arrow because
more Linksys means fewer hares Lynx as
each hares and then you can extend this
to as much as you want to map out your
system just don't go as far as this F as
at the Afghanistan guy just keep it keep
it simple oh by the way if you want to
draw your own systems and actually see
it play out in a simulation a few months
ago I made a tool called loopy a tool
for thinking systems seeing and playing
with whole systems and people have been
really great the users have knocked out
all kinds of systems media economics
mental health gene regulation you name
it I started to share this tool because
one I feel like might be actually useful
for you in your own day-to-day life or
it's in your own working mapping systems
and also to I want to prove I can
actually do more than draw stick figures
so putting up a simulation anyway so
that's how you draw loops but how do
these loops behave there are three kinds
of feedback loops they are one the
reinforcing loop this is when something
accelerates itself an environmental
example heat makes the ice caps melt
which means more dark ocean water which
traps more heat which means even more
ice melts so on
Oh battery this is sometimes called the
positive feedback loop but I feel that's
really misleading you know words are
terrible because they think I'll pass it
if it's really nice but then the ice
caps note and it's like oh that's bells
not positive at all so that's why a
reinforcing loop kind of imagine say a
ball on a hill you push the ball just a
little bit and then it starts
accelerating and accelerating down the
hill and this kind of feedback loops
whoops this
generates exponential growth and
dramatic decline but now there's also
the opposite kind of loop so number two
balancing loops this is when something
undoes itself and economics is full of
these kind of examples say there's a
suddenly a shortage of something so to
supply drops but lower supply means that
prices go up prices go up means that
there's a higher profit incentive higher
profit incentive means that producers
crave more supply and so it undoes
itself and this is also sometimes called
the negative feedback loop but that's
again misleading because your body's
full of negative feedback loops to keep
you alive so it's not really that
negative and again you can visualize
this as a ball in a valley
if you need to give it a large shove it
will move back to original back to its
original place eventually and this kind
of loop tends to create graphs like this
things that go to equilibrium or
oscillate around a point or some mix in
between where oscillates and then
dampens and then goes to equilibrium but
now here's our most bizarre kind of
feedback loop number three chaos and
this isn't actually a loop but it's a
reason why loopy systems are so
unpredictable I want to give a concrete
physical example let's consider two
pendulums swinging side-by-side they
don't interact with each other so right
now is pretty predictable but if you to
put a pendulum at the end of another
pendulum so that is a feedback loop
between the two pendulums
you get chaos you get like one of those
of robot arms from that short video
earlier and it's not just that this is
like really hard to predict like you
know it's been mathematically proven in
chaos theory that the smallest amounts
of error makes it completely impossible
to predict so and this is no we're not
even talking about the climate or the
economy or foreign policy this is a
pendulum it's two pendulums
[Music]
so so what can we do with these
real-world systems so the moral of this
story is that prediction is for chumps
but what does that mean she does I mean
we should give up no think about say
pinball game
it's totally chaotic system you can't
predict it even one second in advance
but that doesn't mean you can't have
better or worse players in fact to
become a better player what you have to
do is create a tighter feedback loop to
quickly see what's happening in the
machine and quickly play with what's
happening well well play with machine
visual inputs tangible output see and
play these are the three tools that help
us map systems reinforcing loops
balancing loops chaos but if these tools
can't predict our course how can they
guide our course well these tools
provide a very strong piece of guidance
which is this fight loops with loops
concrete example think about a simple
thermostat none of that fancy nest stuff
just good honest thermostat like you
know a thermostat doesn't use the
navier's stokes fluid equations - simile
and predictor thermodynamics in your
house no it's just a simple balancing
loop if it gets too cold turn up the
heat
if it gets too hot turn off the heat and
it's yeah imagine the ball in the valley
it just keeps it out of equilibrium if
the thermostat doesn't predict the
future it doesn't even remember the past
and yet this humble thermostat can keep
you nice and cozy during a windy day
and that's how we should approach
complex systems not by trying to predict
whatever in the future because
prediction is for chumps but by changing
the loops loops with loops we can create
a reinforcing loops to increase the
things we value and create a balancing
loops to maintain the things we value
just like how Elizabeth McGee showed
that with one simple change we can
transform a vicious cycle into a
virtuous cycle maybe with one simple
change in how we see in understand
systems we can outsmart the Hydra so
right now I live in Boston there on the
East Coast many of my friends there who
has been there for a while they have a
story they all remember the day that
keep your eye on a arrow they all
remember the day that this happened on
August 14th 2003 several states in the
American Northeast and Midwest part of
Canada experienced what was then the
second biggest blackout of all time in
the world 55 million people lost power
some of them lost power for up to a week
and what could cause so much chaos given
that no foreign power has ever taken
down America's electric grid especially
on this scale who was this master
criminal who has successfully launched
an attack on our own infrastructure the
culprit was a tree
it was a nice summer day
so people turn on their air conditioning
which heated up the wires and because
metal expands when is heated that caused
the wires to sag and it's sagged enough
that a tree in Ohio could reach to that
wire and set it on fire which is okay
this is actually normal this happens all
the time but I mean the trees probably
don't scream when it happens but you
know it happens all the time and this
was usually only result in one station
one power station being knocked out but
due to a software bug they couldn't send
an automated alerts to its neighboring
power stations so it took it's a
electric load and it passed it off to
its neighboring power stations which
caused them to overload so they passed
their load on to their neighbors which
caused them to overload which created a
vicious cycle that swept throughout the
entire northeast causing a blackout this
isn't the only example of something bad
cascading throughout an entire network
for example the 2008 financial crisis a
handful of banks in the u.s. made some
bad bets then something happens and then
grease burns that's because we're living
in such a connected economy for better
and for worse or think about epidemics
one patient zero a little bit while
later millions die beste because were
already connected again for better or
for worse and underlying all these
systems is something called attractors
they called attractors because they
attract the system towards different
things in this case they all attract the
system towards failure and I think the
best way to understand attractors is if
you can guess to see them so imagine you
have a ball on an office shaped hill and
let's say that the left right position
represents you know how good or bad
something is
so if the balls way on the left okay
that's good that means none of the power
stations have failed and all the banks
are still alive but the ball was all the
way to the right that means power
stations have all failed the banks are
all bankrupt I also want to clarify that
the up/down axis is not good or bad it's
stable or unstable
so if something's really if the ball is
really high up in the air it's pretty
unstable but if it's down grounded close
to the earth it's pretty stable and now
stable and unstable again words are
terrible they have positive and negative
connotations but here's the thing here
we have a good but unstable situation
and also a bad but very stable situation
and these mountains are what we saw
earlier reinforcing loops a ball on a
hill so for example you know AB one
reinforcing loop in the power station
example is power station fails it
cascades on to the next ones or a bank
fails in that cascade on to the next
banks it keeps the ball rolling and the
valleys those correspond to balancing
loops ball in the valley for example for
the power station example you know
eventually you run out of power stations
to make fail and for banks eventually
you run out of banks to make bankrupt so
the ball stops at the bottom of that
Valley and these valleys are the
attractors because they attract the ball
to a certain point in this case failure
so now you imagine you are standing next
to this ball and you're a complete jerk
so you push it a little bit and with a
little small nudge it gets past a
tipping point and then gravity takes
over the ball will quickly roll down the
reinforcing loop of the mountain and
into the balancing loop at the valley
the attractor the valley of death and
furthermore you can see that if you were
to go down and actually be nice for once
and try to undo all your damage it would
take you a lot more effort than what it
took you to push the ball in the first
place
all the way down that's why a blackout
can cascade in a few hours but fixing it
took weeks or why the recession can
spread around a globe in a few months
but fixing it took well we're still
living through the consequences
sometimes you have the opposite problem
instead of one bad thing cascading
throughout the entire network the entire
network has already failed and you're
trying to fix it but as soon as you try
to fix one part the rest of the system
conspires against you to try to make
your part to fail again in
systems-thinking jargon this is called
an intractable problem but we can also
understand this visually as well just
flip everything around so now we have
you know same hill as before but slipped
around left to right and let's have the
bad thing on the left and a good thing
on the right now so let's use a example
from peacebuilding left is war right
this piece so you are a piece builder
you want to put in a lot of efforts it's
gonna take a large amount of blood sweat
and toil to get that ball up to the
small little piece value up there it
takes a lot of effort to create a
ceasefire to push forward a peace
agreement to build a whole new
democratic government but the problem is
even if you succeed all it takes is a
little bit of chaos and all your hard
work has been undone and I mean recent
history has given us a lot of examples
of a new peace deal or a new democratic
governments collapsing back into chaos
tragically because that is an attractor
of doom you can also visualize this
through simulations so here's one
simulation that I made in emoji
hopefully is better than the emoji movie
um so yeah you can visualize cascade
failures through play so here's the
simulation I made out of an epidemic so
these are healthy people but once little
small push of chaos the ball keeps
rolling it affects people it kills
people and everyone dies well almost
everyone knows half of them are okay
yeah so a small of a shove and the ball
rolls down to the attractor of doom oh
and for the record a public health
organizations actually use models like
this to not predict but planned and like
combats epidemics in real time a
feedback loop they don't do it in a
mochi but you know they do use models
but yeah it's really hard to make things
right and it's really easy to break
stuff
are we condemned to just be like
Sisyphus just keep pushing the boulder
up the hill and wait for it to fall back
down to do it all over again well only
if we think like Sisyphus only if we
think they're moving the boulders are on
the option the real moral of this story
is don't just move the ball move the
hills which sounds ridiculous but if you
hear me yeah so in the short term it
sounds that moving Hills will be a lot
less effective right um yeah you moved
the hills and you change the hill slowly
but it still seems that the balls
trapped in the same valley you move it
again and the ball seems still seems to
be trapped in the same valley but one
day you change the hills just enough and
now with a very small nudge boom you can
get it to where you wanted to get in the
first place and so not only is it now a
lot easier to nudge it to the next
Valley it's also a lot more stable
remember uptown is unstable stable and
so the deeper the valley is the more
stable that system is in its new place
and how do you change the hills you do
so by fighting loops with loops you can
strengthen or weaken reinforcing or
balancing loops to different actions on
two different of loops that's four
different strategies so you can
strengthen a reinforcing loop to make a
mountain taller you can strengthen a
balancing loop to deepen a valley you
can weaken a reinforcing loop to make a
mountain shorter and you can weaken a
balancing loop to make a valor valley
shallower and remember again valleys are
attractors
so you can weaken or strengthen
attractors at different points to guide
the ball the system into the place you
want to go increase the stuff that you
do value maintain the stuff that you're
also value and vice versa for the stuff
you don't want there are multiple
valleys in all these examples I've given
Peter T Coleman complexity scientists
who applies systems to peacebuilding has
said something really interesting in his
book the 5%
he knows that policymakers usually see
peace as the absence of war that is they
mostly try to reduce conflict and assume
that that's equivalent to peace but
that's linear thinking and these
diagrams show us that that's not enough
that even if you make the war valley
shallower that's still not enough
because you also need to deepen the
Peace Valley or create an entirely new
valley where there wasn't one to four
creates a new attractor because peace is
not the mere absence of war health is
not the mere absence of disease success
is not the mere absence of disaster a
mountain is not the mere absence of a
valley let's have a story that's not
depressing for once
sometime in the Oh 1970s Thomas
Schelling a political game theorist he
was sitting in an airplane flying above
his hometown in New York City and from
far above Tom started thinking about a
huge problem that exists not just in New
York City but also here in SF and really
all the major American cities which is
this we are very divided by race so
here's the visualization from the New
York Times dots of different colors
represent different races as reported in
the US Census and this is how it is like
a few years ago and imagine has been
much worse than Tommy Schelling's time
so why is this the most common answer
and a partially correct and important
answer is that it's a lot of top-down
stuff redlining public housing policy
zoning etc but what is that that's not
top-down like
white flight or immigrants enclaves
nobody had a theory for how that could
happen yet until Tom done an idea like
Elizabeth McGee 70 years before he would
simulate this complex system as a board
game so imagine this old nerd making a
board game on your flights that's Thomas
Schelling
so this game is a one player game and
it's called segregation solitaire really
catch your name
so step one is you pull out your a
checkerboard or you draw your own
checkerboard in step two put down some
pennies and dimes the pennies and dimes
would represent different races and the
checkerboard represents a set C grid
with each square being a house or a
place where you can live so to start
your a game place a bunch of pennies and
dimes randomly make them well mixed but
leave a few gaps for you know leave a
few empty spots so they can move so they
can move later not how this actually
starts off really integrated every coin
has a coin of a different type as its
neighbor and now how do you play this
game what's the rule so there's only one
rule and it so is this each coin thinks
to itself I'll move if less than the
third of my neighbors are like me these
are pretty tolerant coins oh I can't
hate penny some of my best friends are
pennies I love dimes they have such an
exotic culture
so yeah these are relatively tolerance
coins if they they're only upset of less
than a third of the neighbors like that
which means that every one of them is
actually okay being a little bit in the
minority so even though this is a pretty
tolerance rule on the individual level
level has this playoff play out in the
full game so let's play the game
step by step first you have to look for
coins who are who are unhappy so here
we've got two dimes one unhappy one
happy the top dime is unhappy because
only one out of five of its nearby
neighbors I like it and the bottom one
is happy because two of its five
neighbors are like it the first one
that's less than a third of its
neighbors so we move unhappy coins to a
random spot the important thing is that
you don't think about this in advance
you just move it to any random empty
spot but now this causes a cascade
because this coin is now unhappy now
only one out of four of its neighbors
are like it so it moves to a random
empty spot and this happens to pennies
as well and this keeps happening and
happening and happening voila and now
our coin society is totally divided from
the bottom up so even though every coin
was pretty tolerant on the individual
level on the collective level we get a
completely divided and segregated
society and this happens every time you
play this game it's in a tractor state
it attracts it to this kind of
separation this division and today we're
just so Tom created this as a cautionary
tale and today we're separated we're
still separated by ethnicity and race
but also by ideology Billy Bishop wrote
the book recently called the big sort
which argued that a lot of a lot of the
political polarization was singing
recently has been driven by exactly this
bottom-up mechanism people are migrating
to places towns cities that are more
ideologically like themselves and so
that's creating a reinforcing loop of
polarization
anyway Thomas Schelling chased this idea
for the next couple decades and he won
the Nobel Prize happy ending for him for
the rest of us we still gotta deal with
hits oh by the way if you want to you
know not have to pull out coins and
mentally calculate factions in your head
you can play this game that I made with
vihart it's called it's an adaptation or
a shelling segregation solitaire called
parable of the polygons so yeah instead
of pennies and dimes you have triangles
and squares and just like how Elizabeth
McGee extended the landlord's game with
a solution called prosperity we've
extended shellings game so shelling
created showed us the problem and we
extended it with the solution how to
reverse segregation how to create
diversity from the bottom up which I
won't tell you about you have to play
the game to see it when a whole bunch of
individual parts which are simple but
snap together to create a completely
unexpected hole that is called emergence
which is jargon and words are terrible
so usually people describe this by
saying the whole is greater than the sum
of its parts this is a quote from
Gestalt psychologists Kurt Kafka this
phrase is actually a mistranslation of
what Kafka was trying to say the phrase
is better translated as the whole is
other than the sum of its parts
emergence is everywhere in our culture
economics politics any human endeavor we
are capable of both the wisdom of the
crowds and the madness of the crowds and
lying between them is dangerously thin
and it's not just humans emergence is
also found in all nature we've got more
Amala cues that form snowflakes termites
that build complex architectures an ant
step create and act out a really
efficient search algorithm for food
I feel like what the most beautiful and
powerful reason to understand emergence
is is what biologist eel Wilson called
Concilium the idea that we can unify not
just all the sciences but also the arts
and humanities so here we've got physics
that emerges into chemistry that emerges
into biology that emerges into
psychology that emerges into sociology
economics politics history and
technology so emergence I feel like is
our best contender for what could really
unify the Arts and Sciences and
everything we care about
now emergence is not gonna be a theory
of everything but it could be a theory
of everything in between
so what I just gave you a very vague
word for a very vague pattern that
exists in some systems well let's get on
the brass tacks well what what are the
actual elements of emergence what are
the specifics here how do we how does it
work so to understand the elements I
like to visit an example from one of my
most cherished childhood memories I was
12 or 13 small very small and I was
living in Vancouver at the time and we
wouldn't need a water I I don't remember
why we were there but I remember what's
Reef and starlings oh you loved
starlings as well tens of thousands of
them they're beautiful and really creepy
there's like a silence shape-shifting
Lovecraftian sky beast some form of
alien intelligence that you just feel
that just gazing upon it that your minds
gonna unravel but in a good way because
it's really beautiful because these
starlings also presents a mystery
there's no boss darling organizing
choreographing all this stuff so how did
they put forth this stunning collective
dance nobody else by 1986 the now
leading theory was put forth by a
computer scientists Craig Reynolds quick
Reynolds made a simulation called Boyd's
which is how New Yorkers say Birds poit
here's a more modern implementation of
his program as you can see it produces
some pretty lifelike behavior even in 2d
um and what's even more impressive is
that the algorithm is incredibly simple
there's just three simple rules and they
are rule number one align your direction
with other nearby Boyd's so pretend
these chairs are Boyd's
I'm here they're all facing this way
so I align myself this way well number
two is move towards the other Boyd's
so pretenders are Boyd I'm here okay
over there I'll move over there oh yeah
there's a clicker I forgot as a clicker
I can actually move so move towards
either Boyd unless rule number three I'm
too close to the Boyd's
and so in rule number three tells me to
get the way to avoid crashing into other
birds also note that rule number one
it's actually a reinforcing loop because
aligning one Boyd creates more alignment
which forces the other nearby boys to
align as well and then other two rules
are actually a balancing loop because it
gets me towards in equilibrium between
how close to between too close and too
far it's balancing loop so that's it
there's our two three simple rules that
creates these majestic flocks of
starlings from the bottom up but if you
want even more lively behavior you need
a little pinch of chaos so starlings
flock for the same reason that gazelle
moving herds or fish school in schools
yeah
to throw off predators and so yes
darlings only do these majestic dances
only when there is a predator like a
hawk that's my best Hawk that's what
you're gonna get in any case you need a
source of chaos but also you need a lot
of starlings because 2 sonics is not a
flock you need tens of thousands you
need a dense network of interactions so
finally here it is what's entire talk
has been building up to the elements of
emergence reinforcing loops balancing
loops chaos and the dense network of
interactions so if you want to create a
map that can help guide you through a
complex emergent system the parts of
your map your drawing tools are these
faller and four elements and these are
the elements you should look out for
reinforcing loops balancing loops chaos
network of interactions and we can
actually simplify this a lot a lot
further you could say that
reinforcing and balancing loops are
actually selection because they force
the ball to roll smoothly into a valley
and attractor while the other two
elements chaos and interactions creates
a variation chaos is like a ball that is
just really yeah chaotic like that and
interactions are like a whole lot of
balls just smashing against each other
so that creates a lot of variation so
variation and selection or in other
words evolution evolution requires a
really fine balance between variation
and selection you have too much
variation and that's just random noise
you're not gonna get anything useful but
here's something that I truly believe
that um in terms of our culture and our
cultural evolution we are putting way
too much focus on selection you know
create incentives for the things you
want create sanctions for the things you
don't
one's nudge-nudge this much that
optimize and that's fine but one if you
do too much selection you can get
trapped in the in a short-term solution
or the jargon in evolutionary biology is
local Maxima something like that and
besides but also neglecting the whole
other half of evolution variation so if
you're working the environmental issues
you know that is healthy ecosystem needs
biodiversity so it stands at a healthy
human society also needs diversity
yes diversity in gender race capital D
diversity that's important but also
diversity in ideas beliefs backgrounds
skills solutions that's so on and so
forth and so here are some tips about
how we can increase the variation the
chaos and interactions in our own
society instead of implementing one
top-down solution we could invite
multiple competing solutions from the
bottom up instead of separating out
people are into different
specializations we could invite
serendipity by allowing people to across
fields to interact and instead of asking
people to increase productivity let them
also increase play to do stuff that's
completely useless
because stuff that's useless is random
and stuff that's random is a variation
and variation is the real source of our
evolution so how do you design evolution
the answer is you don't that's crazy
totalitarian talk don't do that
what you can do is design for evolution
so that one respects people's own
autonomy because it's bottom-up and two
by designing for evolution but not
designing evolution the system itself
can surprise you with solutions that you
never even thought of
in fact evolution is such a good
engineer that even our human engineers
are copying evolution there's rocket
nozzles and antenna that is designed
with these things called genetic
algorithms which stimulate evolution but
for antenna and rocket nozzles and it
makes much better solutions than humans
could come up with alone so the whole
time we've been thinking of chaos as an
enemy a dragon to slay but maybe just
maybe we can make chaos our friend think
about chaos like fuel if you're not
careful thank you for getting a
reference chaos is fuel if you're not
careful it could set everything on fire
but if we're clever and we're careful
chaos can be what drives us all forward
and one of my favorite quotes that comes
from actually used to it is this
evolutionary design is healthier than
visionary design evolution greater sine
revolution evolution over revolution
because top-down solutions usually go
the way of our British colonialists and
they're cobra bounty but bottom-up
solutions where the hole is
other than the sum of its parts those
are messy chaotic completely
unpredictable and the most beautiful
things that our universe has to offer
so it turns out that math didn't
actually say here be dragons it turns
out only two historical maps have done
so and one of them is the hunt
Lennox globe which was created in the
year Oh 1510 and it's a beautiful piece
of work it's a small hollow copper
sphere it's four and a half inches wide
and imagine like this is 15 Ken no one
has seen a photo of the entire earth and
at this point you could cut the whole
world in your hands and this globe the
map of it was completely wrong it was
hilariously wrong Africa is like shrivel
up like you in a bath Asia's stretched
out like Laffy Taffy where's North
America it's just not there but as much
as we can laugh about this map um keep
in mind our own maps not geography but
of the complex systems that actually
affect and impact of real people
millions of people our maps of those
systems are not much better but we got
to start somewhere
and a start to that tanana piece of
paper so in this talk in Wow 50 minutes
already I've given you three tools tools
to map systems loops attractors and
emergence and with these tools you can
see and play with systems drawing just
playing around doodling and these tools
are just scratching the surface there
are dozens of other visual tools like
this stock and flow diagrams
two-dimensional attractors evolutionary
Fitness landscapes and so on but these
three captured the core ideas of systems
and these core ideas will be our map and
again a map shows us yes what we do know
and shows us what we don't know but most
importantly they exist to guide us so
here's my personal guide for how we can
tackle complex systems together one
fight loops with loops to change the
hills
and three make chaos your friend so now
that we have these tools our maps in our
guide can we finally slay the dragon of
complexity the dragon of chaos and the
answer my friends is a very confident
but here's something else we can do we
can see the dragon honestly truly get
our out of our old linear mindsets and
honestly understand see this dragon for
who it really is and then we can play
with the dragon we'll have to interact
the dragon no matter what but we need to
consciously decide what kind of game
were playing
are we playing Monopoly or Prosperity
and we can deepen that feedback loop
between us humanity and the complex
systems that shape our lives the dragon
and although we will never be the
Dragons master neither does the dragon
have to be our master we can make chaos
our friend and together as a whole we
can be other than the sum of our parts
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
way to go you mentioned in passing
toward the end there Fitness landscapes
you want to see a little bit about how
because evolution is sort of what you
got to you and what are Fitness
landscapes so Fitness landscapes they're
similar to the ball and Hill examples I
showed earlier but all right imagine let
me get the ball imagine we have a
landscape this chair um so I finished
landscape so instead of so not really in
my early example the ball fell down
towards the valleys but in Fitness
landscapes the ball is alive and it's
trying to get up
it's kind of trying to crawl up the hill
however it doesn't have eyes so I can't
see very far so even though it may crawl
up the hill and they realized anything's
oh I'm at the top so therefore I am at
the very top but it can't see very far
so it might miss out on a bigger hill
like me so that's an evolutionary
fitness landscape and it I guess it
functions effectively the same as
attractors it's just you know flips
upside down and actually a lot it's like
evolutionary mathematical yeah
mathematical by law by biologists do use
two dimensional attractor diagrams to
show how things evolve over time so the
as I recall one of the sort of lessons
of Fitness landscapes because the ball
does and they have I is it it's sort of
trudging up the local hill and it
doesn't see the fabulous mountain over
here and just behaving locally and
without eyes how can it get from that
local Maxima to have a try and what
might be a higher heel how does that
work variation variation Seymour yeah so
if a ball and this well this I guess it
just is less true for and this might be
true for biological evolution as well
but I'll start with how some evolution
inspired
rhythms so I'm gonna use I'm gonna try
to avoid jargon um yeah so as you
mentioned there is like the problem
where a ball can get stuck up a local
Hill but not know about its global Hills
mm-hmm the global taller Hills like me
and so one thing you can do so the only
it will get stuck only if it believes
that only if the ball only goes up hills
but if you have some variation some
chaos and allow the ball to move down
hills if you allow a lot of variation so
like this ball Moo slid it down
and bit of chaos ask you to go all the
way down and then even move even further
up if the balls are really lucky it can
finally find a place that's actually
taller than the previous Hill and then
you can start climbing up to a bigger
global optimum a bigger hill you're
using chaos to give the luck a chance
but you're using chaos to give luck a
chance yes of course you're also giving
bad luck a chance when you're do that
that's true so see yeah that that's why
species go extinct
yeah machine actually is a big
explanation for why so here's an
evolutionary puzzle why why does sex
exist because if you think about it it's
pretty costly that has half your
offspring not be able to reproduce on
their own so so the the leading
hypothesis right now is that you know if
it allows for a lot more variation you
can vary 50% of your offsprings genes
imagine if 50% of your genes right now
we're randomly mutated that would not be
very good for you so mutation alone
John Holland actually proved that
evolution by mutation alone could not
work you need recombination which is why
this is the leading hypothesis for why
sex exists even though it's so costly is
that that extra variation which is the
source of evolutionary adaptation is so
advantageous that is worth making half
your offspring be unable to create a new
offspring mm-hm
by itself yeah sexual selection
supposedly sexual reproduction came
along we and parasites came along yeah
and so the parasites reproduce really
rapidly the organisms are kind of going
along and just you know basically
cloning and then the parasites could
always beat them they couldn't evolve
faster than the parasites unless they
figured out the chaotic workaround which
was sex right sex is pretty chaotic
it's San Francisco I can make this show
San Francisco is an attractor NOAA asks
in your game of trust explanation you
sometimes show things concretely
animating each move sometimes abstractly
graphing an entire tournament how do you
decide between Wendi be concrete in the
wind choose show abstraction I was
really inspired by this interactive
essay by Betts Victor who is called
up and down the up and down the ladder
of abstraction and so his essay starts
off really concretely and in steps one
level above the it goes one level up in
abstraction and it goes another level up
in abstraction and so on and so forth so
so that's the kind of pattern that I've
been using in all of my interactive
simulations and games is starting off
super concrete and then building up the
abstractions but as I mentioned earlier
like understanding does not come from
going higher and higher than
abstractions I guess like it's better
think of it rather than going up the
ladder of abstraction every time you
pull on the rung you're actually
bringing the entire ladder down go back
go back to that complex diagram that
military guy was showing if we
understand the diagram will win the war
yeah
and so say that set of generals brings
you in to help to understand what's
going on in a complex situation like say
Syria and you get your security
clearance you're in the building they're
showing all these various things
interacting and water how are you gonna
help them do something more actionable
and understandable than that
Graham that defeated them okay first of
all I'm not gonna be able to solve Syria
in like the two minutes I'm answering
this question up here of course but
would you be getting them into how do
you move the hill how do you look for
what are the reinforcing loops that are
making a good thing happened that you
can make stronger is that sort of the
approach you feel like yeah if I were to
apply the three sorry
chaotic ball are the three lessons from
this talk fight loops with loops mmm
change the hills and make chaos your
friend okay yeah okay is not always good
I guess yeah a better way to say chaos
is variation um and so I would say it's
all working you know say okay let start
with the whole variation selection thing
first that's like guy number three I
would I think about a lot of the
solutions in Syria have been very
top-down and that's a lot of solutions
and a lot of the peacemaking community
has been very top-down and I feel like
it would be very beneficial to try more
bottom-up solutions that get the local
community like have to love the
community drive more of the efforts
which I know is a lot easier said than
done so again I'm not solving this right
here but uh if I were to apply what I
just talked about on to conflicts like
Syria that's how what I would recommend
so one local community story you tell in
your business surrounding the the
prisoner's dilemma game that you're
developed is the Christmas truce that
happened in World War one want to say
what happened and why it was interesting
so for just background so the Christmas
truce in the year 1914 sorry your oh
nine teen 14 weren't along now but the
AU is upfront it was World War one and
at the Western Front the battles between
the German and British trenches on
Christmas everyone
you know a lot of the trenches not all
them but a lot of them soldiers on both
sides of the trenches put down their
guns
the trenches walked across no-man's land
and celebrated Christmas together they
buried their dead they sang songs and
they exchanged gifts and so they're
really like amazing thing about this
Christmas truce is that it was actually
not unique they really had a truce
I'm very unofficial truces long before
Christmas so they had something called
the live-and-let-live system that
emerged from the bottom up spontaneously
across many of all a lot of the trenches
in fact the the top down
the officers were explicitly trying to
prevent this they would order there so
just all right you have to shoot them so
the live in that system is you know you
don't kill me I don't kill you so even
when the so this is I really like the
story even when the officers were
directly ordering the soldiers to fire
their weapons the soldiers would fire
the weapons at very precise targets at
the exact times on every day so that
each other each army could learn each
other's patterns and even though they
would be shooting they would both live
and so if you play my game the evolution
of trust it's an explanation of how this
trust can emerge from the bottom up
using Robert Axelrod game theory of the
iterated prisoner's dilemma and the
whole business series I recall is it's
solved by iterated prisoner's shown that
the people keep playing it they
basically catch on to the thing that the
troop has figured out that you can do a
workaround and pretend to be having your
or but actually nobody gets killed yes
that's that's why a trench warfare is
unique in a amongst like all kinds of
warfare because unlike most kinds of
warfare you will most likely not seen
see the same specific enemy soldiers
twice if you have you have not done your
job
but with trench warfare you will
encounter and faceoff the same specific
soldiers over and over again being the
same specific closers is incredibly
importance it was just the same general
flag or enemy
then this does not work but if the same
specific individuals then that's an
iterated prisoner's dilemma and in that
case cooperation can evolve so there's
another version of local it's not just
they're not abstract they are specific
yeah and specific gives you that chance
to do the workarounds but Kevin Kelley
asked can your insights be used not just
to understand whole systems but to build
them like I age yeah it's like robots
like an artificial life which copies
these things
I like how you accidentally misspoke and
said I a because I a is actually amazing
say more so AI artificial artificial and
say it today words are terrible AI is
artificial intelligence mmm I a is
intelligence amplification okay and I
think a few decades ago there was this
like big debate about AI vs IA and the
work I do I feel like is more aligned
with AI a it doesn't at least the
philosophy of it seems like the classic
way I right now is to replace human
thinking or at least parts of human
thinking but I a augments and amplifies
our human capabilities so as I mentioned
the way we advanced is not by flowing up
an abstract and it's by getting amazing
abilities and bringing it down to our
human level so I just like showed off a
lot of complex and really chaotic
systems and it was all done with human
capabilities of drawing and seeing and
that human that very unique human
capability of play and so it doesn't try
to replace those human capabilities it
augments them by I think I shouldn't
talking on some core chaos I've been
playing her that so much or war yeah so
the all these drinking element it's kind
of a book plug here this is John Markoff
spoke machines of loving grace or you
basically spelled out the history of the
the are the history of that argument
between a
and I a and not surprisingly he comes
down on the augmenting intelligence
which was sort of the Doug Engelbart
mother of all demos kind of thing work
with the human as the the thing they're
like man anyway to answer your question
Kevin yes so the emotional simulation I
didn't show it but it is programmable
and it's programmable through English
you you select the sentence as you want
and all the code is in plain English and
also loopy you can program it by drawing
so right now this are the only tool two
tools I've made so far but the nice
thing about a pen and paper is that
that's all the tools you really need to
understand systems deeply I feel like
one weakness in my work that I want to
you know work on is that it's really
hard to make it interactive and if I
were to like like it's really hard yeah
for someone else to make it interactive
because code is just still stuck from
forty years ago but with a pen and paper
you can do that you can draw your own
systems tomorrow or tonight if you want
she made loopy originally this dynamic
he made prisoner's dilemma game that's
dynamic what's the next interesting
problem that you would like to resolve
that way I don't like solving but
explaining you know knowing is half the
battle
yeah make visible yeah what tool were
jointed at all um I really want to talk
more and like show more about human
cooperation because I feel like that's a
really important theme especially right
now but also you know in general okay I
want to go into jargon here but I want
to explain stuff like Elinor Ostrom z--
governance of the Commons how people
govern comments from the bottom up so
that so the traditional story is that
you know tragedy of the Commons rational
people will mess up the comments
entirely unless they have a central
authority or it's privatized but Elinor
Ostrom has shown empirically and
theoretically that yes people can't
do manage the Commons from the bottom up
and that's definitely very very
important today not just with
environmental issues but also Commons
like democracy or norms or culture or
economics so some of the sort of rules
that she think she inferred by seeing
these systems fishing systems and water
providing systems and so on there were
self self managing in a healthy way over
the long term there were things like
they needed sort of a boundary yeah and
they needed things like that there were
rules that everybody basically had to
understand and agree on but there are
also rules about changing the rules so
that they could improve this system or
this is infinite game kind of stuff
which would be another great project for
you
thank you I'll make a note on the game
like that one or we can all relax and
this actually comes to a question that
Kevin Kelly raises long now foundation
falling now as last 10,000 years that we
can draw on the next 10,000 years we
feel sort of responsible for and how
does the kind of tools that you're
making clear help that process of
basically long term thinking long term
acting long term responsibilities long
term embracing I mean in a way the
vicious cycle you showed at the very
beginning was the things goes faster and
faster and faster until it breaks yes
and what are what emerges what you've
got already or from what you might have
helped us get that would increase this
kind of long frame to activity all right
so I'm not sure if this contradicts some
of the long now members but as I
mentioned our first prediction is for
chumps right so you cannot predict you
know the future yeah like 20 years ago
people didn't like both 50 years ago
people predicted flying cars and all
that kind of stuff but no one predicted
you know the internet or smart
phones and also for the record flying
cars that those are called helicopters
so yeah if you can even predict 50 years
in future and technology is only
accelerating how would we predict
anything ten thousand years in the
future so what I was proposing instead
in my talk it's not to predict the
future but create strategies for the
future I feel like people really
conflates the words planning and
predicting I feel like there I've come
to completely different things
so yeah you can plan for evolution which
is sounds paradoxical because evolution
is all about stuff that surprises you
and there is no foresight in evolution
but you can plan for it you can create
decentralized systems to allow for
variation we can allow people across
fields to interact which you know
creates more creativity so I feel like
and I feel like this fact that strategy
or variation in selection and thinking
about feedback loops and changing the
attractors I feel like that could last
10,000 years because it's worked for the
last 3.5 billion years of our evolution
so it should work hopefully so one of
the things which is emerged in control
theory is that if you respond too
quickly to stimulus you can get into a
just a total zero cycle and but if you
build in a delay and they're trying to
do this with the things in the stock
market for example because it got so
fast that it caches various directions
and the Cascade gets going and so you
know what's the how would you explain
how that sort of delayed response
process works yeah that's what I
mentioned in the changing the hills
section okay so we have the stock market
that is a mountain because there's a
reinforcing loop and thanks to
technology that's well robots not even
stockbrokers of robots trade stocks at
milliseconds Cascades can jump from
robot - robot immediately so this this
mountain is now
well it's just a big long mouth and I
guess mm-hmm so if you wanted to and you
know having an incredibly long Johnson
if you fall off the top that's really
bad mm-hmm so changing the hills
adding those delays would be the
equivalent of weakening those
reinforcing loops which is the
equivalent of making that mountain
shorter you know more human scale so if
you fall off you probably don't break
everything mm-hmm I like it um hereis
yeah here's the ball mountain Ted give
me that ball not for you the answer is
the question that Molly asked are there
examples of negative of negative loops
that were result on extinction of either
or both actors sorry negative negative
negative loose if that's the same as
positive the positive dad that is
actually yes the equivalent of positive
feedback loop because you have to
multiply the you know yeah it so if you
have less than so a B minus minus less
of a causes more sorry more of a causes
less of B but because it's flipped
around unless it be causes more of a
which causes less appear each causes
murmuring which ones must be more more
more of a it's a classic
negative feedback loop that is a
positive feedback negative negative
double negatives are positives right
that's right he said so that is how he
[Music]
right well the better question
Gerald Harris oh sorry Molly that wasn't
no that was Molly's was is a negative
negative my favorite well my favorite
but I guess my nose I don't think that's
a good negative negative loop um okay
personal example or at least my favorite
personal example motivation and
depression okay here we go it's a
negative negative loop more motivation
means less depression supposedly and
more depression means less motivation so
it is a vicious cycle it is a positive
feedback loop again I yeah reinforcing
loop is the bit words are terrible it's
a reinforcing loop because if you're
more depressed that means less
motivation but less motivation means
you're more depressed which means less
motivation more depressed it's a vicious
cycle
it's a reinforcing loop so there we go
that's a concrete example of how a
negative negative loop can be a
reinforcing it's a great girl Gerald
Harris as a piece of music is this
system now listening and you pick up the
system if you thought about mapping
music or if you thought about mapping
with music that's interesting it's the
first thought that pops the - that you
experience sound completely linearly you
know what we'd love to work on this
would be with Brian Eno all of our other
speakers actually yeah you're right I
should have said you experience sound
linearly because I know um you know I
thought about that I guess the question
the answer is regression is the answer I
have not thought about that we'll try it
maybe Jam lovino well you guys together
see what happens
thank you for doing this this is great
[Applause]
[Music]